[موسيقى]
يروى ان جماعه كانت على سفر بارض اليمن
فوضعنا دجاجتين للعشاء حضرت صلاه المغرب
والطعام جاهز فتركنا
واقاموا الصلاه اتعلم وهم يصلون اخذ دجاجه
وهم ثم حاد الثعلب وفي فمه الدجاجه وضعها
بعيدا عنهم وتنحى هجموا عليها واذ هي ليفه
خديعه وليست دجاجه وبينما هم يضحكون هناك
كان التعلم قد هاجم هنا مجددا وسرق
الدجاجه الثانيه وفر بها اكل طعامهم
وباتوا دون عشان تروي هذه القصه عن الامام
الشافعي وما هو بقاء لها وينسب ايضا
للشافعي دون تاكيد قوله لا تاسفن على غدر
الزمان لطالما رقصت على جثث الاسود كلاب
لا تحسبن برقصها تعلو على اسيادها تبقى
الاسود اسودا والكلاب كلاب تموت الاسد في
الغابات جوعا ولحم الضان تاكله الكلاب وذو
جهل قد ينام على حرير وذو علم مفارشه
التراب
الى العناوين
مرسل الى الحريه اول المنتخبين واخرهم
ابن سلمان تربي عند يهوديه في قصر ابيه
ابو ظبي تحوم حول سقطت وتفشل
اردوغان يدعو مكروه الى تغيير مهنته
نصف النظام بوتفليقه يعتقل النصف الاخر
حيث يعيد تمثيل مرجان احمد مرجان
[موسيقى]
لا تقتلوا اسود بلادكم فتن كلكم
الكلاب اعدائكم
هيمن الاسود محبوسه والضباع مستاثره
ليه فستذكرون ما اقول لكم وافوض
امرى الى الله
مرحبا صور اعلام الجنرال زنزانه الرئيس
وكانها فندق سبع نجوم يتلقى نزيلها رعايه
صحيه وغذائيه مبهره حتى كنا نعتقد بان سبب
اغماءته المزعومه ناتجه عن ارتفاع
الكوليسترول بالدم اما الاعلام المقابل
وحرص على تكرار ان الرئيس المقتول
بالكوليسترول
هو اول رئيس مدني منتخب ديمقراطيا في مصر
وربما يكون اخر رئيس ديمقراطي اذا طال عمر
قال عمر
مع انه في حسبه لغويه سريعه نجد ان القرار
في اللغه من اسماء النهر وضع الدم مع
النار القراءه وبهذه الخلطه يقول الشعبويه
من البوفيهات يصبح السيسي اكبر رئيس منتخب
ديمقراطيا
تعلم اللغه ضروري لفهم السياسه ليس امس
امبارح وانا م فكروا جهاز مكالمات او
مكسيموم تلفزيون طلع جهاز مخابرات العقيد
سامسونج فضحتهم وديعه مبتدئه في قناه اكثر
نيوز فقرات فوق نيوز اكثر تعليمات حول وضع
مرصد طبي مدير
تم الارسال من جهاز سامسونج
جميع الوثائق الطبيه التي تؤكد تقديم
الرعايه الصحيه له موجوده تقدم ان الجهات
المعنيه
بينما كان سياسي يضع اكليل الزهور في
العاصمه البلاروسيه مينسك على قبر الجندي
المجهول كان الرئيس المعلوم يسقط على خشبه
محكمه في المشهد الاخير خارج كل العدسات
ما اريكم الا ما ارى وبقي لعشرين دقيقه
للصهاينه
[موسيقى]
حساب الظل سموه التسامح محمد بن زايد في
التويتر كما يوصف في اوساط خليجيه ابدع في
تقديم نفسه
فوضع صوره لمرسي وعلق كان بحب الوسط
واللحمه دينيا ما الها سامه واستحضر من
الارشيف صوره اخرى معلقا كان حافه مواطن
الرئيس مخلوع الله يرحمك الله يرحمك
يازايد الخير ما كنت تقبل بهذه اللغه فجر
السعيد من الكويت تفوقت على خيال العيال
فجلست فوق سطرين تحضر الارواح وتصالحت مع
ذاتها و لذاتها في نبش القبور ومحاكمه
الموتى الحلوين الاثنين ان شاء الله
طبعا صاحبه واجب ولا يصحوا ان يقصروا معها
في رد الجميل بعد عمر طويل وانا قلت لك
موعدكم يعني انا بحط صوره بال بال اه بال
هذا عند
مناصرون الاخوان ردوا عليها بانها تركز
عدائها على الاسلاميين وهذا ليس منصفا قبل
شهور قليله بهدله الجزائريين لانهم
اختاروا ملكه جمال لم تعجبها فاعتبرت
الاديب فجر الملكه الجزائريه حيوان
ووصفتها بملكه جمال الابل
هناك منصور اخر
الاعلامي مسابقه مزايين الابل ملكه جمال
العالم هذا ليس انتقاد يا ستي يا ختياره
ولكن هذا قله ادب ووقع لذلك ساحترم فارق
السن بيني وبينك يا فجر السعيد فانت الان
بمقام جدتي واعتقد كذلك ان نعقد كلفته
عمليه ايضا انتقدت صفحات مؤيده للاخوان
نشر الخارجيه السعوديه بعد ساعات على وفاه
انفوغرافيك يصف جماعتهم واصل الارهاب عقد
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك عبد الله بن
عبد العزيز مباحثات مع الرئيس المصري محمد
مرسي الذي وصل الى جده في اول زياره
خارجيه له بعد ان تولى منصب الرئاسه وكان
في استقبال الرئيس المصري في مطار جده ولي
العهد السعودي الامير سلمان بن عبد العزيز
ولان الدنيا كما يقول ابو وديع سلف ودين
وكانت الرياض اول المهنئين بالاطاحه
الدمويه لحكم مرسي وجه خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك عبد الله بن عبد العزيز اه
برقيه تهنئه لفخامه المستشار عدلي منصور
وفي ذات الوقت نشد على ايدي رجال القوات
المسلحه كافه ممثله في شخص الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح السيسي اعلام السياسي الذي ركز على
سيناريو الموت المفاجئ لمرسي كان يناقش
الموت المفاجئ قبل يومين لم يفاجا
المشاهدون بموت مرسي لكنهم فوجئوا باختيار
موضوع النقاش هي الاعراض اللي تخليني اخاف
اننا من المرشحين
سؤال غريب شويه من المتوفين الغريب ولا
حاجه بوش يمكن بردو تم الارسال من جهاز
سامسونغ عمرو اديب غرب لن نسمح بوفاه مرسي
فنحن لا نفعل كما يفعل الاخوان لتعلق عليه
الاعلاميه اللبنانيه مريم البسام
تفكر اذا بتسع على الهواء يعني صارت صحفي
بلا زغره هايذي من عندي بل واجب تتحقق
بظروف وفاه الرئيس السابق
ربحنا زميله ومن نيه انكم
[موسيقى]
السياسي المخلص يبشر مصر تقدمت معه في
مكافحه كل انواع الفساد كل يعني كل لقد
قطعت
شوطا كبيرا خلال السنوات الاخيره في مجال
مكافحه
الفساد
بينما كان
اصلاحات كان العالم سياده القانون الصادر
عن مشروع العداله العالمي
الترتيب العربي والعالمي الوضع الحالي في
مصر
على الجميع ان كان كان عدم وجود
اي مبدا فصل السلطات نلاحظ ان الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي هو رجل
الموجود في السلطه الذي اه
جميع السلطات السلطات
الصهيوني
علاقات
ليس فقط بل ان يعتبر ان
اسرائيل اكثر من كثير من اليهود
سيده يهوديه
ما لم يقله ما يكفي البحرين قاله ادى وزير
خارجيه المنامه تخطى الصهاينه بتغريداته
مش ملاحقين عليه خصوصا وزير الخارجيه
المحمد
ورشه البحرين التطبيعيه تتحول فلسطينيا
الى مؤتمر الخيانه النائمه في المنامه لن
يكون هناك فلسطيني شرف ومن يشارك
فلسطينيا بالخيانه
وفي تونس سياحه الاسرائيليه حضرت فيها
هتافات لجيش الاحتلال
علما ان وزير السياحه في تونس يهودي
[تصفيق]
من المعالم التي حرص الاسرائيليون على
زيارتها منزل الشهيد خليل الوزير الذي
اغتالوه بانزال بحري عام ثمانيه وثمانين
انهم يمجدون مجرميهم وبعض اعلامنا يجرم
خليل الوزير وعبد العزيز الرنتيسي
لكن الوقت الان ليس لفتح الجروح مع
اسرائيل فايران هي البعض ونحن الباب يا
بيبي هذا الحب عن البعد الذي اخاف الحاله
ولابد من ايقاف انا لا اعمل الاعلى
استهدي بالله يح يخلي امل كبير هذا زميلك
ينتقل من حروب الفيديو جيم الى افلام
الخيال العسكريه والخيال خيال سيطلق على
ايران الف وخمس مائه صاروخ تقدير في ليله
واحده سيفشل الامن السيبراني الامريكي
حركه الاتصالات هناك اكثر من سته وثلاثين
هدف استراتيجي ستصرف بنفس الليل اللجنه
تختلف مع عميد بحريا سعودي يحمل واشنطن
وحدها مسؤوليه التصعيد فتنتقل الشاشه
المصدومه الى فاصل مع الاعلان ما يحدث
الان الملاحه انت الولايات المتحده
الاتفاق النووي عليها ان تتحمل شائعات في
جامعه انا اشكرك الامير على البحر القاعده
امر الامن المحلل العسكري كنت معنا من
الرياض وعذرا على باحث اخر يستعين ب مثل
شعبي لاستجداء التدخل الامريكي الثالثه
ثابته
فتاثر المعلم وارسل له ثلاثه فواتير كتب
عليها والرابعه مرعبه والخامسه حاسمه
والتاسعه تعيسه الاعتداءات حصلت اليوم
للمره الثالثه وفي العرف العربي المثل
العربي يقول الثالثه ثابته اذا لم تقم
واشنطن بواجبها في النظام الامني الاقليمي
ف سياتي من يملا الفراغ الحالات مش هيك
الحروب
كل شي صار وق بمطار ابها وانتهى واكثر يا
عزيزي التصعيد لم يبدا بعد هذه مجرد تذكير
للدول العالم والتصعيد قادم الامارات لم
تسقط على تهديدات الحوثيين تحركت
ميليشياتها المحليه لانتزاع سقطره من
الشرعيه اليمنيه التي تقاوم الحوثيين او
ما يقوم به المجلس الانتقالي الليبي
سقوطها هي محاوله احتلال حاله خطره وكل
هذا مدعوم اماراتيا وهذا مستشار الرئيس
اليمني يعلن ان هذه سيعود الى عدم وفي حال
تم منعه فعليه اعلان ذلك
تقبرني عندكم قنصليه بالسعوديه منتبه بدو
يحكي بيحكي من فرنسا يقدم طلب لجوء ويحكي
ضميره انا اتصور ان الاخ الرئيس سيعود من
امريكا داخل ايران هنا لم يستطيع وفي هناك
موانع اعتقد ان ال ان الواجب الوطني
والاخلاقي التحدث بصراحه ومن صحيفه الرياض
دعوه واقعيه لترا بان يتخلى عن لعبه القط
والفار مع ايران على امريكا ان ان تعلن
صراحه هي اه تتخلى عن لعبه القط والفار مع
ال الجانب الايراني القرار في النهايه ليس
عند المحللين بل عند ولي العهد وقت قال
كلمته
كما لن نتردد في التعامل مع اي تهديد لكن
المملكه لا تريد حربا مع ايران فهل تقبل
ابو ظبي الاصوات الان التي تقول لا للحرب
حيث تدافع عن مصالح ايران في السياسه
البراغماتيه ليس مفيدا ان تبقي على موقف
واحد
المهم ان تبقى رابحه وكما غريمه واطال
عمره اغنيتها الشهيره
احسنت انت الربيع واعتبر الامير السعودي
ان الاضطرابات السياسيه في المنطقه مصدرها
التنظيمات الارهابيه كدا عشان واليوم وجدا
عشر مفيده لقد استخدمها ولي الحق دوله ان
افعلها والقاعده القاعده من التي انشاها
في البدايه فكر القاعده اسامه بن لادن من
الذي اشار في البدايه الولايات المتحده
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه بكل بساط
والاخوان ان يكون لاحظ انهم الاخوان
المسلمين جماعه ارهابيه
العلاقه بين الاخوان المسلمين والملك
السعودي علاقه تاريخيه بالاضافه ل سياسات
النظام العراقي الراعي الاول للارهاب
والتطرف
[موسيقى]
وزير سعودي وسفير سابق اسمه ثامر السبهان
سبحان الذي خلقه بيمسك الذهب لم تنتج به
الرياض في مهمه ال او اخفق فيها من العراق
الى لبنان واليوم تحل بركته على قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه الكرديه في دير الزور
اليها الى الاتراك عقدا في حقل العمر
النفطي في دير الزور اجتماع ضم كلا من
وزير الدوله السعوديه الثامنه سبها ونائب
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي والسفير الامريكي
وعددا من شيوخ ووجهاء واداريين من قبائل
ومجالس ان يحرص بعض عمالقه الفن والرياضه
على الاعتزال بعد انجاز يعتقدون انهم لم
يحققوا افضل منه الامير تركي الفيصل لم
يقرر بعد الاعتزال ويشغل نفسه الان بتقييم
وطنيه دول مجلس التعاون و يوزع شهاداته
عليها هناك خطر مع ايران والبقيه مع دول
مجلس التعاون سمو الامير ليس فقط قطر في
اعلامكم الكثير من تخوين عمان وشوي الكويت
واعلام كم ك اعلان قطر المحلي لا ينطق عن
الهوى معظم العقائد هناك في عمان هي
مذهبيه او اثنيه مع طهران مسافه السكه
تعود من جديد مع الاكاديميه السعودي خالد
الدخيل الذي سال عن موقف مصر من دور ايران
منذ ست سنوات لم يصدر عنها موقف واضح بل
تكبر القاهره مواقف مطاطه مثل امن الخليج
من امن مصر يرد احدهم انتم جربت موسى وقطر
جربت اردوغان الذي يريد صداقتكم تحت سقف
القانون وتصفونه بالمجنون كل هذا الخوف
سيؤدي ب اردوغان الى الانتحار الى التخبط
لذلك الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدرك
جليا الان انها لا تعطي مجنون اسلحه ضخمه
مثل ال اه الفور
الاخ يعرفون عنه بانه مفكر لكنه مفكر بان
صواريخ اس اربعمائه امريكانيه ولا يعرف
انها روسيا لا هو ولا مقدم السهره ولا
الجالسين على
الصواريخ بيعرفوا
تعود الى الواجهه مع تقرير اممي يطلب فرض
عقوبات على بسبب مسؤوليته فيها كما تقول
الامم المتحده الموضوع لم ينته بل لم يبدا
بعد كما يبدو
تذكرون
قبل سته اشهر
الرئيس الفرنسي ولي العهد السعودي على
خلفيه الجريمه
صحيح نعم
انا
اعتقد انه يستطيع ان يتكلم بهذه اللغه
الاعلام مع الرئيس التركي
انقره من التنقيب عن الغاز في تركيا
دعاه الى تغيير مهنته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اه
في الجزائر اقتياده الوزير الاول السابق
احمد اويحيى الى السجن بهذا الموكب الامني
حرم سيده متظاهره من استخدام بيض الدجاج
لاطلاقه على جبينه تحيه وهو الذي كما يقال
اكل البيضه وتقصير ت ها مع زميله وعسير
الفساد عبد الملك سلال اعتقلا بفارق يوم
واحد وتشابه في التهم
اذن نصف نظام بوتفليقه في السجن بامر من
النصف الاخر من يحاسب من
ومن كان خارج المقاصه وقوائم القبض الخير
الشعب هو اللي يدير المحاسبه السليمه لانه
الحكومه الحاليه اللي فيها وزير العدل
الشاطر ارادتهم
حياتي جمع في تقليد الشخصيات حتى الان بين
حي وراحلين السياسي والقذافي وعلى صالح
ينزلوا عشان الدين وتفويض وامر باني اواجه
العنف والارهاب المحتله
عسكري ما كان في سلطه ولا مش في سلطه
لكن
ومدينه مدينه
يمشي في نفس حتى وقع في الفخ فقلنا عادل
امام في فيلم رجع
والمقصود به الدعم السريع
في الوقت
لقد
على
[موسيقى]
لقد وقعنا فى الفخ
في السعوديه يتواصل التفاعل مع اخبار
افتتاح ديسكو حلال شو في جده مع انتشار
مزيد من الفيديوهات من داخل النادي الليلي
فؤاد الهاشم يعترف بالتجسس على قطر ويخلص
الى ان القطريين لا يرتادون المرابع
الليليه في الدوحه وهي بالمناسبه ليست
قليله بس هون ما بياخذوا الحرمين بيحبوا
الامريكان بقاعده العديد
بعض الاصدقاء
ما تخلي بارما تخلي
وتشوف الدستور يعني لا ادري مواطن
[موسيقى]
ختاما اعجب الغراب ب مشيه الحمامه تحدث
نفسه ما الذي يمنحني من التبصر مثلها وبدا
بالتقليل وبدل في ذلك اياما كثيره وفي كل
مره كان يفشل ويتحول الى مسخره بين الطيور
استسلم في النهايه وعاد الى رشده والغراب
لا يصح ان يصبح حمامه لكن المفاجئه انه
نسي مشيته الاصيله طبيعته هيئه التقليد
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
الله
ام
[موسيقى]